perfecto en todos los vídeos anteriores
hemos estado platicando acerca de la
derivada implícita y que con ella
podemos obtener la pendiente de la recta
tangente en un punto de mi curva en esta
ocasión lo que quiero ver es encontrar
en efecto esa pendiente de mi recta
tangente y voy a suponer que lo quiero
encontrar en el punto x igual a 1 y
bueno antes que hacer la derivación
implícita lo que a mí me gustaría saber
es cuánto vale y es decir en qué punto
estoy para 2000 curva por lo tanto lo
que voy a hacer es sustituir a x por 1
en esta ecuación y despejar allí
entonces vamos a hacerlo 1 elevado al
cuadrado pues me da 1 entonces lo
primero que hay que poner es 1 y después
tengo más bien menos equis vale 1 más de
menos uno elevado al cubo es igual a 28
ahora voy a pasar el 1 restando de otro
lado y me queda que ye menos 1 al cubo
es igual a 27 y después le voy a sacar
la raíz cúbica entonces me queda que
menos 1 es igual a la raíz cúbica de 27
lo cual es 3 y entonces y es igual a 1
no lleva a ser igual a 3 más uno que es
4 muy bien entonces tengo el punto 14
estoy parado en este punto de aquí y es
justo ahí donde quiero encontrar la
pendiente de la recta tangente entonces
para eso lo que necesito es la
derivación implícita y para derivar en
precisamente lo que hacíamos es agarrar
el operador derivada con respecto a x de
ambos lados de la igualdad la derivada
con respecto a x de este lado y de este
lado y bueno pues vamos a realizarlo
entonces la derivada con respecto a x de
x cuadrada es una cosa muy sencilla es
2x entonces tengo 2x y después tengo la
derivada con respecto a x de yemen os x
elevado al cubo y como se resuelve con
la regla de la cadena exactamente hay
que bajar el exponente ponemos otra vez
la función original de menos x le
bajamos 1 el exponente es decir al
cuadrado y después hay que multiplicarlo
por la derivada de lo que está dentro la
derivada de ella con respecto a x esta
derivada de ella con respecto a x
y la derivada de x con respecto a x es 1
y bueno del otro lado tenemos la
derivada con respecto a x de 28 lo cual
es cero porque la derivada de una
constante es abajo y ahora si lo que yo
quiero despejar es la derivada de ye con
respecto a x por lo tanto lo que voy a
hacer es en un principio multiplicar
este 3 que multiplica a x menos de
cuadrada tanto por la derivada de ye con
respecto a x como x menos 1 entonces
primero me queda 3 que multiplica a
yemen
x elevado al cuadrado que multiplica a
su vez a la derivada de ye con respecto
a xy le voy a poner aquí y después me
queda 3 que multiplica a yemen os x
elevado al cuadrado que multiplica a
menos 1 y me queda menos 3 que
multiplica a yemen x
elevado al no menos x elevado todo esto
al cuadrado hay que tener mucho cuidado
un errorcito y el error puede ser fatal
y ahora sin esto que está aquí lo voy a
pasar del otro lado y lo vamos a pasar
con signo contrario por lo tanto voy a
escribir otra vez todo solamente lo que
depende de la derivada de ella con
respecto a x
es esto que está aquí y me queda tres
veces menos x elevado al cuadrado la
derivada de ye gon respecto a x esta la
voy a dejar de color magenta recuerden
que es tras lo que vamos y esto lo voy a
pasar del otro lado y me queda menos 2 x
menos por menos me da más entonces esto
lo mismo que poner tres veces menos x
elevado al cuadrado menos por menos me
da más y después es menos 2 x no más
menos 2 x este es el paso positivo y el
otro se vuelve negativo y bueno por lo
tanto la derivada de ayer con respecto a
x la derivada de y es en color magenta
perdón aquí está la derivada de ella con
respecto a x es igual a 3% menos x
elevado al cuadrado todo esto menos 2 x
entre 3 por james x elevado al cuadrado
y ahora sí si yo lo que quiero saber es
cuál es la pendiente de mi recta
tangente o la derivada de ye con
respecto a x pero en el punto 14 lo que
tengo que hacer es sustituir la x por 1
y la ye por 4 por lo tanto vamos a ir
poniendo todo esto vamos a ir
sustituyendo con calma y me queda 3 que
multiplica a ye que vale 44 menos 1
porque la x vale 1 elevado al cuadrado
menos 2 veces x que vale 1 entre 3 veces
ya que vale 4 - x que vale 1 todo esto
elevado al cuadrado y esto que es igual
4 - unos 3 al cuadrado es 9 por 3 todo
esto es 27 9 por 32 27 entonces es 27
menos 2 y esto me da 25 entre 3 por 3 al
cuadrado de entre 27 entre 27 claro está
y bueno aquí ya tenemos por fin la
pendiente de la recta tangente en el
punto 14 en esta curva que tenemos aquí
que por cierto no les dije pero esta
gráfica la saqué del programa world
alfa y por lo tanto ya tenemos todo y
hemos resuelto este problema espero les
haya servido